okay here we are um I'm sorry I was just
a little verklempt at seeing two icons
together
I am so knocked out to be able to meet
her I feel such a hero to me Oh pleasure
to meet you you'd been awesome for all
of us further thank you okay
start making out you two
why you want to watch myself it's a
beautiful moment let's ruin it PJ
O'Rourke why are there so few mainstream
conservative comedians oh it's so true
you're the only one who can make that
[ __ ] funny it seemed funny to us well
there are a lot of mainstream
conservative comedians is just not on
purpose right and Ted Cruz you just me
up you just don't have the material to
work with I'm sorry there is no Sarah
Palin for you guys on the left no you
know I mean you can try to make a
equivalency with Nancy Pelosi it just
doesn't work you may not like Nancy
Pelosi but she's bright what more that
we lacked a Tina Fey than we like the
yep yeah well but I say that yeah I
think we have proven over and over again
to be hilarious so just watch Ted Cruz I
don't really see how you could be much
funnier okay um glory is the Equal
Rights Amendment still worth fighting
for oh I forgot all about this yeah what
no what year were they trying to pass
them it's coming back it is 78 yeah
coming back if there's a big populist
movement for it because I think that
we've realized looking at say the
Walmart suit which was a huge the
biggest sex discrimination suit ever
that we lost it because we couldn't
prove state of mind you know hello you
know not because there wasn't
discrimination if we had the Equal
Rights Amendment we would have wanted it
you know it would be nice to have women
in the Constitution sort right
Armstrong Williams where does the ben
Carson campaign go from here I saw a
headline today it said it was circling
the drain
I'm just saying I do know that don't
believe everything you read
I know but he did fire people today he
needed to okay and cut sometimes we need
to find cuts out yes yeah so you
understand that well that's part of
that's part of corporate discipline
corporate you got a car struck
especially when you leave I well you
don't need those people more you just
got a cut that's what happened what
about the fact that he went home to get
new clothes uh are we real O's clean air
bill again let's be fair and I think the
ladies can relate to this don't take it
personally right away when you've been
on line and don't eat clean clothes yeah
course disappoint when you've been on
the road for eight 18 days sometimes you
need to change things but I just I mean
come on really
yeah eighty day but but he has no one in
the campaign who can go get them for him
no no no he had to go home himself
listen it has been on his it was on his
schedule form online
really yes was a laundry day
come on mother I never wanted you to say
he wanted to sleep in his own bed I
totally understand this one in the same
this sounds like you know it's America
ready for a president you don't hurt you
know I promise he's not a politician he
just says exactly what it is I'm going
home I need a change of clothes somebody
else Ted Cruz would have said it
differently dr. Carson is just authentic
that's who he is putting it on the
change coach doesn't have no more no
less
it's not a flunky who could go get his
clothes no no no he's got to pick him
out himself he wanted to go home he
wanted to go home all right leave the
clothes out of it right exchange about
men's obsession with clothes and fashion
and cleanliness and so on not about
connection with him you want to go home
no yeah want to go all right uh I
thought it might be funny but it wasn't
is critical we've all been there his
criticism of Hillary's vote for the Iraq
war still fair game
well of course she's in a campaign what
sort of question is that but buddy huge
vote but wait a minute
Obama was big enough to say that if he
had been in the Senate at the time I've
got the same false information about
weapons of mass destruction he didn't
know how he would have voted really I
mean that I thought was a very
gentlemanly and creative I don't Obama
to say that I remember him making a very
forceful speech no those are so
prescient today about how dumb it would
be to get involved in Iraq he wasn't in
the Senate at the time it was before you
yeah he was in Chicago in a street
rallies same when you read it to it he
he said that if he had known the same
thing that Hillary knew he might have
voted differently I thought that was
great of him to say that okay uh so you
so somebody else has is the country
ready for a female president it seems
kind of on the nose yes and also I know
that Hillary's campaign beats this to
the into the beating a dead horse but
let's just think about who we are as a
country if America follows up the
election of its first black president
with the election of its first female
female president I mean that
moment for us is American I mean we
won't forget about Donald Trump having
ever run and and and it would be it is
it a reason to vote for someone just to
know I'm not for it but I do see like oh
no never served I nothing well we're not
voting Michael this election sorry
should go for the gutter blood we're not
voting on Sarah Palin excuse me we're
voting for a woman who represents the
majority of women and no but you know
what percentage of black voters did
Obama get over 90 no Democrats always
get that that's because he's a Democrat
well it is it may not do with they don't
get over 90 yeah but I don't think
Hillary is getting over 90 percent of
women it just doesn't work this name
well any daughters not the reason it
doesn't you want to know why they're
sort of interested in Bernie Sanders
they were sort of interested in in Rand
Paul doing they were but they as to
whether a candidate was which gender or
of what separate persuasion and it isn't
seem very significant but there there is
a deep reason I think with women often
which is that most of us are raised by
women whether we are women are men I
mean there are many more we raised by
women wait wait that's my point there a
lot of no no that's my point okay
because we are raised by women even
though there are a lot more great
fathers now than they used to be but
because we're mostly raised by women we
associate female authority with
childhood emotionality irrationality you
know so like the years we see no no it
still look at all those studies we see
men's Authority later and it seems more
rational and appropriate to the outside
world so I really don't think we will be
able wait a minute we will be able to
something new for me yeah good I'll keep
Tom no no no because we we will really
only be able to recognize human talent
in all of its forms when men are raising
children as much as women are and women
are in the public world as much as men
are
do you think in the fact that recent
studies have shown that when men when
husbands participate a lot in the
child-rearing like you know very young
especially changing diapers their
testosterone levels drop yeah Oh Dean
your alcohol intake is OSes I'm here to
tell you there's there there's there is
the fight-or-flight testosterone - which
but women also have testosterone
incidentally there's also the oxytocin
which is the tendon befriend hormone and
that goes up in both men and women when
we hold children when we're with each
other and empathize with each other this
is not a bad thing
I mean testosterone poisoning is not
what we want because wait wait wait let
me speak up for - someday we do want
some test attracts apprentice Osterman
does a lot in the male body to regulate
everything else you need to stop yes and
women need testosterone too less I'm
just saying okay they don't need it like
me I need it we needed imbalance we
don't need just some crazed Warriors
going on tested no but there's a happy
medium and when a man changes a diaper
it could threaten his health that's all
I'm saying
true don't ruin
it's just true it's not [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's child shut you can't talk
with us bill keep talking it's just the
truth um need a drink and by the way yet
eighty countries in the world have
elected a woman leader mm-hmm so know
isn't it amazing yeah I mean America
should whether this is the year or not
America should feel embarrassed about
yes baby
yeah countries I mean you're often late
on a lot of stuff you were the last
country to get rid of slavery one of the
last major countries but do we have
under war over that one yeah right we
have to have Golda Meir Oldham a
[ __ ] oldest always scared me I I would
love to have Golda Meir well look she
certainly looks good this year doesn't
she yeah no she never looked good Wow
and your broom right the show is called
real man Alex do you think that the
DNC's decision to add more debates to
the Primus schedule have a positive
impact for either candidate on represent
I mean last night was a great example of
that I just think you have to
substantive people talking about
substantive issues that's good for the
country that's good for the party that's
good for people is it turned on to the
Democratic okay okay I'm sorry but
apologize to my the public in French but
it does look like just a whole different
species yeah when the I mean they had
this subset of discussion among two
adults who never went out of the bounds
of decorum talking about what
progressivism is they're just on a
different level of the evolutionary nail
and let's be the neck
I mean you can't you the circus is on
the is on the Republican so much more
fun it is more fun Gregory or somebody
does is a New Yorker yes longer New
Yorker Rick and I say a word about Trump
is a New Yorker please he is not a
successful business I thought you know
that's true there's a guys with time to
do the story about what his real net
worth is but you seem out of success
because people oh he is they're not a
success really yeah no he is assessing
well oh man he's a con man yeah wrong
they were wrong as well you're taking
100 yeah taking the two hundred million
dollars he inherited from his father he
was born on third base that's true
absolutely you know if he had taken the
same amount of money and invested it he
would have made more money than he has
now he where thanks I'm 300 that he is a
yes he's proud person we don't know that
because we'll never know how much money
he has because he's a giant bubble
economist mr. Khanna must have looked at
this and said that he is not a
successful businessman invested as New
York Times reporter he sewed me well
anyway he lost the elantra you know I
there are many things you could question
John's not a success season no I mean he
just leases his name and puts it on Bill
I actually thought you get rid of
endorsing when you say can I say some of
us wrong yeah please I don't you know
I'm very rich very rich I'm very
successful I'm very smart I had small
that's why saw him yesterday and or
something shamed them from the same city
that he is in he is such will you come
from Toledo Ohio it's okay you come from
Toledo I know you come from well I do we
both do I know what does it say about
the people that support Trump well I
think they're looking for look at
somebody that the primary thing they say
is he's a successful businessman and
therefore you can run the country which
is why I think we need to know he is
only a con man not a successful business
all okay he's bowing
yes saw him saw Donald Trump at an event
in New Hampshire yesterday
oh and that hair thing you know that
Cinnabon
in the person yeah it's just a car lover
it is they don't think it's a we add me
maybe we it's a weed but it's just it's
just a comb-over I really I blend we
settled that thang